现代游戏引擎的理论与实践
那么今天这节课呢
我们要讲是如何构建这个游戏世界
因为在上一节课
我们的小明学会了就是游戏引擎的基础结构
我们知道现在游戏引擎基本上分为五层村
最核心的硬件平台层
到上面的这个核心层
在上面的这个我们的资源层
然后呢接下来是很丰富的
这个就是我们的功能层
再往上呢就是大家每天看到的工具层
各种各样的编辑器对吧
非常的庞大
当然还有我们很多第三方的这个内裤
在支持我们
但是有了这些知识
我们只是知道这个大厦长得是什么样子
但是我们并不知道说这个大厦里面的建筑
这些砖石
这些水电是怎么在一起work的
所以今天这节课呢
将会是一节含金量非常高的课
就是告诉大家说
唉我们怎么去构建一个真正的游戏世界
那么这个如何构建一个游戏世界呢
其实我们就要明白说
这个世界到底有哪些东西构成的
那么这些东西呢他们是怎么去被描述
然后呢他们彼此之间又是怎么被组织
怎么被这个就是调动起来
所以这件事情的话呢就是我们游戏引擎的核心
而且这节课的核心就是
教大家如何去构建这样的一个游戏引擎
那我们继续回到一个实战的例子吧
比如说我们那个聪明好学又非常自信的小明
他学上一节课
假设他学会了如何在一个游戏引擎里面
做一个动画系统
并不意味着他知道如何做个游戏
那我怎么知道如何做一个游戏呢
我们就举个例子吧
比如说小明玩了战地2042
觉得这个游戏很好玩
但又很拉胯太多的bug了
他就决定说
那我就索性自己再做一个游戏引擎
能做一个比2042更好的游戏出来
那么假设他设定了这个目标的话
他首先要去想象一下诶
这个游戏世界应该有些什么东西
那首先的话呢
我们需要对这个游戏事件进行拆解
那首先我们想到的东西是什么呢
是一大堆的这种可交互的动态物
比如说地上跑的坦克
天上飞的无人机对吧
还有端着枪冲着这个NPC的小兵
当然了
还有火炮
还有导弹
看上去非常的酷
这些东西呢它都可以动来动去
可以根据你的行为
甚至你可以直接上去操作这种东西呢
在我们的现代游戏里面
一般叫做动态物
叫dnan game object
那么这一类东西也是大家最容易关注到的东西
那么第二类东西是什么呢
就是默默的静态物
比如说高高的瞭望塔
比如说飞机的机棚
比如说房子
我们在游戏中看到很多东西对吧
放在那边
但是呢它虽然不可以交互
但是它整个构成了我们这个游戏的各种各样的
关键性的game类的元素
那么除了这些动态物和静态物之外的话
那我们还有什么呢
其实是大家最不容易注意到
但是却是无处不在的
比如说地形系统就是无处不在的大地
那么地形系统呢它就会无限的绵延下去
那么它又是我们现在所有的这些
就是这个动态物啊
静态物的支撑的这个托盘
那么在游戏引擎中的话呢
地形系统一般是一个单独的系统
我们在后面讲其他系统会讲到
那么还有大家注意不到的是什么呢
就是我们的天空
其实很多时候大家好
没有注意到我天蓝蓝的天是什么
但其实大家想象一下
就是我如果真实的在一个游戏世界里面
我要保
我要表现日夜的变化
我要表现阴天晴天下雨
大家看到那个天上那个变幻莫测的那些云
其实这样的一个动效和视效
本身并不是特别的简单
就是我们专门有一个说法叫TOD
就是time of the day
就是日夜变换这样一个系统
但今天呢不作为我们这个课程重点的展开
还有一块很大的这个物体对象是什么呢
就是我们的这个比如像植被对植被很有意思
你说它是动静态系统吧
确实它是固定在一个地
一个地方不太能动
但是呢风吹了它
炸弹炸了它
它又有交互对吧
但它本身又有一定的变化
而且植被的特点是什么呢
它的量特别特别大
其实这些东西也会是构成我们的叫environment
环境的元素
那么小明分解到这儿
我们有了动态物
我们有了静态物
我们有了环境
基本上我们就可以画出我们所有能看见的
这个世界了
对不对
但是这个作为游戏来讲够不够呢
其实还不够
因为游戏本身是要玩的嘛
那在游戏中呢其实还存在着大量其他的物体
比如说我们有一个叫trigger box
就是一个一个一个一个检测体
检测体做什么东西呢
它你是看不见的
但是当你走进去的时候
他就知道了
举个例子
比如说我到了一个多七点
我走过去的时候
诶
我的积分就可以一直在涨
一直在涨对吧
包括我们去玩那个游戏的时候
我们最讨厌的东西是什么
比如说空气墙
那些空气墙的话
那也是一个物体
对不对
我相信大家玩战地的时候最讨厌的东西是什么
就是我开一架飞机飞得正嗨呢
突然告诉我说你已经飞出了war zone
然后五秒钟之后就把你击落对吧
但是这个东西我是怎么知道的呢
可能又放了一些你看不见的东西
甚至包括整个这个游戏玩法的规则
它其实也可以抽象成一个物体
所以呢就是在现代的游戏中的话呢
我们会发现就是说无论你是静态的
动态的还是啊
当然大题和填空是独立的
但是像游戏规则啊
像检测题啊
我们都会把它统一的抽象成一个叫game object
游戏对象
那么这个game object的话呢
在行业里大家会经常把它就是缩写成叫GO
注意啊
这里的GO和我们那个go那个语言
不是一个东西
包括围棋的英文go也不是这么练
我们一般都叫GO
就stands for game object
就是在现代游戏引擎中呢
我们一般会把所有的这些东西全部的统一
抽象程叫做game object
这就是这个一个方法论
就是小明这样一想哦
我明白了
我要构建这个游戏世界
那我就是要管理好这一系列的这个game object
就可以了
好那我们就知道了game object
那有了game object
我们怎么去做一个游戏呢
那首先我们就举个例子
比如说小明想
那我先做个最酷的吧
比如说一个可以自动巡逻的无人机
对不对
那么它在战场上会飞来飞去
会帮我监控整个战场的环境
这个听上去非常的酷
那这个无人机怎么去做它
那我们去分析无人机的行为
那无人机你会发现
当你去描述一个无人机的时候
你一般会得到两类的东西
第一类的东西叫什么呢
就是它的比如说它的外形对吧
它的外面的几何用三角形表达的外形
他的各种动画
还有他空间的位置
还有它的血量
还有它的那个油量
它的电池量是多少
这个东西叫什么呢
我们统一的叫做属性property
那么另外一个东西是什么呢
这个无人机它是不是可以飞来飞去对吧
它可以move
可以移动
同时呢它还可以可以就是说去巡逻
它沿着某个固定路线
或者有一定的AI算法控制台可以去巡逻
它可以追踪一些人
那这个本身呢是一些API的行为
你会发现就是说啊
当我们在游戏世界里描述所有的物体的时候
它你可以把它归类成两类
一类叫做property
一类叫做behavior
就是属性和行为
你基本上就可以描述几乎所有的物体
那么在游戏引擎设计中的话呢
我们也是按这个进行分类
那么假设我们会去这个写最简单的
同学们的语言
无论大家是学java呀
还是学这个啊
C语言还是c#
whatever就是只要是现代语言面向对象的
你会很自然的就会说诶
那我们定义一个类
比如说我们定义一个类叫无人机john
那你看到我们会把所有的它的属性
定义成它的这个property对吧
各种变量
比如说你的位置我定义成一个三维的向量
Vector3
然后呢你的血量我定义成一个标量
就是比如说零到啊
100这个值
你的油量我可以定义到0~1的油量对吧
那我会有两个我的内屏函数
就是我我的函数定义我的行为
比如说我是不是可以木啊
我是不是可以这个巡逻啊
那么这样的东西是不是一个很完美的一个
类的定义
就是我把我的数据和我数据
所有的方法都放在一起了
其实呢这个东西虽然看上去很土啊
但是最早期的游戏还真的就是这么架构的
非常的简单
非常的直觉
那么你有了这样的一个描述之后啊
实际上我们呢就可以基于它做更多的变化
比如说小明说诶我觉得不过瘾
我要做一个叫查打一体的无人机
我不仅可以巡逻
我还可以看到目标
我可以攻击
那这个时候他就会非常简单了
就说那好
那我再给这个无人机增加一个行为
比如说叫做这个attack攻击对吧
那么的话呢那这个时候我既然攻击的话
我的子弹是不是不是无限的
所以呢我还再加一个它的属性叫做这个armor
它的弹药量是多少
那你看只要再添加两行
我好像一个更多的行为就构建出来啦
同学们如果会写代码的话
特别是大家对有一定的语言基础
这种时候肯定就跟小明一样
很快意识到
那这样我就用对象的派生和继承的关系
我定义一个类叫做无人机这个类
然后呢我再派生一个类叫做查打一体无人机
就是那个COMBRHI
然后这个时候诶我多加一个变量
多加一个行为
这个无人机它就有有了这个攻击和察
打一体的能力
其实这个最早期
这就是一个标准的一个
面向对象的一个思维方式
这个方式呢其实非常的直觉
和我们对世界的认知
其实最早期的引擎的时候
我们真的就是按这样一个面向对象的逻辑
去构建这个世界
但是呢这个方法它虽然非常的简单易懂
但是它有一个缺陷
就是随着我们的游戏世界啊越做越复杂
我们就会发现哎
这些东西它并没有那么清晰的父子关系
我们经常看到很多混血儿对吧
就像我们知道
比如说我们看到一辆坦克
那么我们看到一辆船
但是呢如果我把坦克和船合到一起
我们会得到什么东西叫水陆两栖坦克
而坦克本身呢是派生似于车辆
船呢本身是比如说一艘一艘巡逻艇是派狮子船
那你这个水陆两栖坦克到底他的爷爷是坦克
是车辆呢还是船呢
这个是一个非常经典的
这个就是面向对象的一个问题
这个呢不仅在我们的游戏引擎的架构上
其实在就现代编程语言中
我们也会发现这样的问题
那这个问题的话怎么解
其实那个有一个很经典的解法
也是现在引擎最常用的方法叫做组件化
就是我们把对象拆分成他的行为
拆分成无数的组件
就像这辆玩具的这个挖土机一样的
你看起来是个挖土机
但是我把他的那个铲子换成各种各样的部件
比如说可以把它变成一个小推推那个压路机
也可以把它变成一个小的推土机
也可以变成一个小的举重机对吧
这就是一个组件
可以把同一个模基础
变成各种各样的模块的东西
那么我相信大家的话呢
在现代游戏中最喜欢玩的东西是什么
叫做啊自定义
对不对
比如说我们玩一个现代射击游戏
我们会把枪各种组件模块定义来定义去
我加上一个那个三倍狙
我就是一个就是一个就是一个狙击枪了
对不对
三倍镜我就是个狙击枪对吧
我加上个消音器
就是我一个微冲了
所以呢其实现代的武器
包括游戏设计里面
我们也有大量的这种组件化的思想
而这个思想呢其实在十几年前甚至更早一点
在现代游戏引擎设计中的话呢
我们会用这个思想来重新描述和定义这个世界
那在这里面的话呢
就是回到刚才
我们那个小明的无人机的案例的话
我们重新理解这个无人机的行为
我们会发现嗯它在空间上的位移
Transform
我们是不是给他一个组件
就表示它在空间的各个位置占用关系
然后它的外形我给他做一个组件叫model
这样的话我能够把它的外形表达出来
然后呢我还有一个组件叫motto
motto是什么呢
就告诉我说这个无人机的各种运动属性
比如说它的最快爬升速度啊
它的加速度啊对吧
这些它的这个整个的移动的惯性啊
那还有一个组件是说叫health
告诉我说这个无人机还有多少血
包括他的API行为
它的物理行为
它的动画行为都变成一个一个一个的小组件
然后呢当我把这小组件模块拼到一起的时候
诶我就有一个我自己的无人机出来啦
其实如果动手能力很强的小伙伴
你们现在买现在的很多玩具啊
你会发现它都不是包装好的
都是提供了各种选项
你自己可以去选配
对不对
这是在真实的物理世界
但其实呢在游戏世界里面
我们很早就按这个逻辑去构建
游戏的整个一个基础的物体逻辑
那这个时候啊大家好
会写代码的小伙伴就明白了
就是这个时候就非常简单
我们呢如果假设用C语言为例的话
大家只要定义一个叫component base
一个鸡肋
他同意好这个每一个组件的基础行为接口
这里面大家注意到一个细节没有
我们有个函数叫tick
待会我会讲
为什么每个组件都要拍摄一个tick这个函数
然后呢我们的各位移呀模型啊
他的这个动画这些类
全部派生自这个component pace
那这样的话我们就可以在一个机构里面
管理一组各种各样的component的小组件
在一起就可以协同工作了
那这样的话如果按照这个思想的话
那小明的这个挑战就会变得非常的简单
对不对
那我的这个transform
我的model
我的animation
Model physics
这些东西无论是你是只能飞飞的这个侦察飞机
还是这个我能攻击的超大一体机都是一样的
但是呢因为我可以攻击了
所以我的API可能要换一个模块对吧
ATTACKBOAI的模块
那么呢我本身呢还加一个战斗系统
就是能够帮助我瞄准啊
索敌呀
那这两个组件一换诶
我一架无人机就变成了另外一架无人机
所以非常的简单
对不对
很直觉符合大家的想法
其实这就是现在游戏引擎架构的一个核心理念
就是我们要尽可能符合大家的直觉
为什么呢
因为现代游戏引擎啊
它的整个基础结构
第一个要让我们的开发者好维护好理解
同时呢
我们要交给大量的艺术家和设计师去使用
我们要把这个世界的组织啊
各种交互符合他对天然和直觉的理解
因为我在第一节课就跟大家讲究
隐形游戏引擎的架构本质是什么呢
它不是一个就是我们技术啊
炫耀我们技术多厉害的一种技术炫耀体
它是什么呢
它是一个生产力工具
就是大家很方便很容易去理解
才是我们这个引擎设计的一个底层的需求
而这件事情的话呢
其实是呃我们引擎的行业的一个
基本的一个方法
就是大家如果有玩过
比如像unity area这些商业引擎
你会发现这里面的话呢
他们都会去提供这个叫component的概念
如果大家打开应用例题
点开任何一个物体
你会发现下面出现一小串
一小串的它的各个组件
而且这个组件你可以增加
可以自己去定义
甚至可以给它写脚本
那么在ARMA里面其实也是类似的东西
那么在这里面有个细节啊
就是大家看到就是在如果大家看他们的代码
特别是像aria
你可以看到源代码
你会发现诶他所有的东西就派生自一个you object
那这个呢我这里要跟大家同学们讲一下
就是这个u object呢它不是我们讲的GO
它更像是那个就是我们像高级语言
或者是那个里面讲的
比如像c#里面的object
就是他要确定任何对象的生命周期的管理
比如说你创建啊那个内存释放啊
就是我们讲的GC啊
需要的一个一个句柄
就是我上次讲过那个handle
那么包括unity里面那个object也是这个概念
所以这跟我们的机油不一样
举个例子
比如说像在aria里面的话
更像我们机构的概念
可能是actor拍摄的这些这一系列的东西
那么其实在现代引擎里面的话呢
component组件的这个这个就是说呃
他的这个能力是非常综合的
举个例子
比如说我们在游戏里看到各种各样的光源
比如说无论是点光源啊
还是面光源啊
还是这个方向光啊
在ARMA里面它也会被定义成一个组件对吧
在unity里面的话
各种行为
我们比如说我们的动画这个物体模型都是组件
所以我们用组件作为积木
去构建出了整个这个现代游戏引擎的
这个技术结构
基本上听到这一趴的话
很多小伙伴我觉得如果开发能力比较强的话
已经收已经痒痒了
很想去写这样的代码
其实我在一开始学这些系数的时候
我也是这样的
就是我听了听了我就很想去写
自己去实践它
那么所以呢课程讲的这一趴的话呢
我觉得同学们只需要记住两件事就可以了
第一个呢就是说在游戏世界里面
我们把几乎所有的东西全部抽象成了
一个叫做game object机油这样一个东西
然后每个机油我们用各种各样周功能的组件
把它组合起来
所以component又是GO的原子
那这两件事情基本明白了
你就明白了现代游戏的组合的一个基础逻辑
好
那有了这个东西之后
我们就小明就很自信了
他觉得我就可以
我可以去构建这样的一个游戏世界了
但是你真的想构建一个这样可以打起来可以
这个就是说真正可以玩耍的东西
好像还少了点什么
大家觉得少了什么呢
这个世界是静止的对吧
我怎么能让这个世界真的动起来
这个世界因为这我我的坦克要能开得起来
我的飞机要能飞得起来
那这里面的话呢其实也不是特别的难
为什么
我记得在上节课里面我讲过
就是如果听完我们第二节课
就知道
在游戏引擎里面最核心的一个函数叫做tick
就是我们每隔1/30秒
让这个世界往前走一步
就如同我们的真实世界里面
一个普朗克时间一样
那个上帝
如果我们是生活在一个simulation里面的话
我我我会认为每个普朗克时间
就是上帝给我们设置的tick
那么在我们的游戏引擎里面有一个tick
那这个tick
怎么像我们的游戏世界里的这些对象传导呢
其实非常的简单
就是我把一个每一个机
你的每一个component依次去TK1遍
比如说我的一个坦克对吧
或者一架飞机
那我首先TK一下我的MOTO
直到我现在往前走了111小步
如果我现在知道我的速度是10米
每秒1/30秒0.03
那我知道我现在要往前移动30cm
这个时候我的动画告诉我说
诶我要去卷一下我的履带对吧
那这个时候我的那个那个那个主跑好像转一下
这个时候呢我的战斗系统能告诉我要开一下火
所以在在这30分钟一秒里面的话
我把我的这个坦克的机油里面
每个component一次就哒哒哒TK一下
那如果我们把整个游戏世界里面
所有的物体都tick1遍
我们的这个世界是不是就动起来了
所以tick其实非常简单
所以刚才我们在讲这个component的
鸡肋的定义的时候
就大家如果自己动手
无论你写的是java c#还是CC加加
那你在写component积累的时候
一定要加一个tick函数对吧
但是真实的这个游戏引擎比这更复杂
那你们还有什么pretty postc
我们以后带着同学们在深度的理解
但现在呢大家只要只需要知道
我们有个tick函数就可以了
我们去TIK它
但是呢这个非常符合我们的直觉
对不对
非常的直觉
但是在现在游戏引擎中呢
我们一般不是按照每个对象进行替开的
我们会把一个个系统进行TK
比如说我们先把这个MOTO系统全部替开一遍
所有的物体往前走的
往后走的
往上飞的全部印下来
接下来呢我们会替你的control control是什么呢
就是你的物理碰撞检测的东西对吧
还包括我还检测一些位移的阻挡这些东西
然后呢我在动画做你的动画
我在做你的东西
这东西听上去好像有点反直觉
就好像是说诶我一个人
你为什么一会儿让所有人先动你的头
让所有人在动你的手
所有人在动你的脚
不是每个人把自己的头
手脚自己动掉就可以了对吧
感觉有点反直觉
那为什么会这样呢
其实有一个最简单的一个类比是什么呢
就是大家想象一下
我们假设做汉堡包
那么我们假设一个汉堡店有五个工人
大家最直觉的做法是什么
OK那每个人对吧
你先去烤面包
然后烤牛肉
然后呢洗蔬菜
然后呢放上你的butter
然后放在一起哇
一个香甜可口的汉堡就做出来了
但这样的生产效率高不高
显然是不高的对吧
大家知道我们现在这个工业最核心的概念
叫什么
叫pipeline
叫流水线
那最高效的做法是什么呢
就是有人专门去烤面包
有人专门去烤牛肉
有人专门去洗菜对吧
大家配合好
然后呢到了十天啪一起合成一个汉堡
这样的效率是最高的
而这个这个原因呢在计算机上面的话呢
还有一个很大的一个好处是什么呢
就是我们所有的component的数据
我们都会把它尽可能地集中在一起
这样我一次处理的时候
整个就是一次批处理
大家还记得我的上节课跟大家讲的
那个图灵机的那个故事吗
就是那个无限长的那个纸袋
我说过
就是在图灵机上效率最高的处理方式是什么
我们要把同样的数据尽可能放到一起
然后呢我们一次一次一次把它处理完对吧
然后呢无论读写都在一起做
而这样的架构呢
它的读写和处理效率是最高的
那但是呢这个就是其实我们在我们的高级课程
会讲到那个ECS啊
这个TOTS这样的架构的时候
我们会深入讲
那这节课呢我只是简单的点到
就是让同学们知道就是这样的一个架构
接下来一个tick系统的话呢
就是你直觉得project的tick和反直觉的
每个component的类型的tick
其实在游戏引擎架构中都是有的
但是现代游戏引擎的为了追求效率
逐渐逐渐的会转向
就是按照那个每个system
或者是每一个每一种component的进行tick
所以我想这个东西应该也不是很难
同学们如果真的不理解
就记住一句话
就是我要造个流水线
这样流水线的话我可以批处理
所以我的效率高
就这样就可以了
非常的简单好
所以那我有了这样的一个东西的话
那小明其实不是可以
构建了一个动起来的世界了
我的坦克也能开了
我的飞机也能飞了
但是这个世界呢还缺了点什么什么呢
这个世界是没有交互的
也就是说我坦克自顾自的表演
我飞机自顾自的表演
但是坦克和飞机和人之间没有任何关系
我现在举个具体的例子
什么叫gay gay
比如说我现在跳上了这辆坦克
然后呢我朝敌远处的敌人开了一炮
那好我要把远处的敌人击倒
这个是我的目标
但是诶好像每个GO之间都是自己的tick
我是开一炮
我怎么样的
让那个机油知道自己被我打伤了或者干掉了呢
这里面其实就需要基欧之间
彼此是要能够告知彼此
那这件事情的话呢
其实最简单的想法是这样的
就是来我们坦克开了一炮
这个时候这里面讲一个小小的细节啊
就是说当我一个机油开炮这个行为发生的时候
我这个component可以再去SPA
就可以再生成一个新的机油
那个机油什么叫炮弹
哎
我们有一个炮弹叫GO那个炮弹
那个机油出来啦
炮弹那个机油呢它就自己有一个输出的
对不对
他就每每个TIK就往前跑跑跑跑跑跑
他突然在某一个TIK的时候
他发现自己上一个T的位置和即将要跑的位置
这条线好好像和比如说地面有一个交点
什么意思
说明哎呀我要炸了对吧
炮台说我要炸了
这个时候炮弹说不行啊
我我我光炸弹没有用啊
我得我得炸死旁边的这个
这是我的敌人
对不对
好他就开始就寻找了
说哎我旁边有一个人
我旁边有一个有一个直升飞机
我旁边有个坦克
还有一块石头
那我这样我在我要爆炸的这个逻辑里写道说
我查询一下我周边的这些对象
如果他是人
我掉的人
我要我要见你的血
如果是飞机
我要见你的血
如果是坦克
我要减你血
如果是石头
石头表示说我完全没有影响对吧
但是如果是这样去写的话呢
这个逻辑呢我们叫做hot cold
其实这个东西大家不要笑
最早期的游戏引擎有的时候真的是这么写的
就是大家好多同学会写hot cold
这样就写
但是随着这个游戏世界变得越来越复杂的时候
大家会发现这个hot code它其实是不work的对吧
那怎么办
那这里面我们就有一个更优雅的解决方法
我们这也是现代游戏引擎最重要的一个机制
叫做event机制或者叫事件机制
我们不要那么粗暴的
就直接敲人家的门对吧
跟人家说
你被我打了一下
这样太粗暴了
而且我还需要知道我所有的邻居家
我要认识所有的人
这很麻烦
那我怎么办呢
我给大家写写邮件
你们每个人呢在家门口都放个邮箱
我不需要认识你
我只需要知道方圆
比如说20米之内所有的邻居
我给你们每一家寄一个邮箱
现在我这封邮件肯定不好了
叫我们英文叫做blackmail对吧
就是告诉你不好意思
我打了你
扣了你100点血好
我把这个游戏邮件放在这儿
这样你明天早上起来的时候
也就是下个tick的时候
你突然一看
哎呀
原来我这个这个这个被人家扣了100点血
如果我这个是一个health component的话
假设我这个GO是一个小兵的话
我查查自己说嗯我身上只有70点血
你居然扣了我100点血
那好吧
我只能死给你看了
那这个小明就只能倒在地上死掉了
所以其实你看本来是一个非常复杂的
这个一个框
就一个问题
通过一个简单的事件机制就会变得非常的清晰
而且明确这个呢在系统架构中我们叫做解耦合
就相当于把各个机构机构之间的通讯
本来我们需要知道
所有可能其他的那个跟object对象类型影响
包括每个机油里面的component的类型
这个太复杂了
我们统一的变成了一个叫event的机制
你只要发出一个event给对应的那个CEO
让他来处理就可以了
这样的话
各位机油和component之间的逻辑的话呢
它就是上就结耦合了
这样的话是不是变得就非常的干净对吧
那这个时候的话呢
其实在现代游戏引擎里面
比如说我们讲unity unreal的话呢
这也是大家非常常用的一个机制
基本上所有的商业级引擎
我们都要做这样的机制
举个例子
比如说像unity里面
就是你可以简单的三的一个注册一个message
注册一个event
然后呢三的event这里面它是用一个字符串说诶
damage event好
大家就知道了
然后那个那个物体的health component
他如果收到了这个这个
这个这个这个这个一般的之后
他有一个回调函数被激活
然后它就会调调自己的血
这一切的话用字符串match就可以了
因为ARREAL呢是比较复杂
其实我个人觉得ARRA架构做的太复杂了
其实它是用C加native code去做的
所以你需要一套比较复杂的
这个就是说呃反射机制
就是把C加加里面
你要注册这样的一个event
说诶当这个event发生的时候
这个每个component哪个函数被毁掉
但其实它的基本道理都是大同小异的
那为什么unreal会做的这么复杂呢
因为当你注册这个一个event的时候
如果同学们有现代引擎使用经验
比如说像ROO的经验的话呢
你们会发现就是有个蓝图
对不对
你注册了这个东西之后
那个蓝图就会增加了这样的一种消息类型
然后呢在你在一个比如说你做了一个炸弹的
他的行为的机油的时候
你说诶我撞到地面的时候
我蓝图你们就会说
我要给大家发出这样的一个消息
这个一般的出去
那么另外一个比如说在你做的另外一个东西
他比如health component里面
它就会蓝图里面就会收到
它又可以加一条选项
说如果我收到了damage这个消息的时候
我会怎么去处理
它的本质上就是说能够让这个整个接口
这些消息我们可以不断地扩张去定义
其实大家做游戏引擎啊
最核心的就是要做一个可扩展的消息系统
让我们的游戏开发者可以在我们的引擎之上
可以不断的定制
跟自己玩法相关的各种各样的消息类型
然后呢
他们可以定制各种各样自己想要的component
去对这些消息
对这些事件进行自己想要的逻辑的处理
这就是现在有游戏引擎的话呢
最核心的一个工作
所以讲到这一趴的话呢
基本上大家就知道怎么去做游戏了
但是呢先不要急
这里面还缺一个东西
就是在我们的游戏世界里面
有那么多的机油对吧
在一个比如说单机游戏里面啊
就是大家比较喜欢的一个单机游戏里面
一般是几百个这个洞的机油吧
但是在有很多游戏里面可能到几千甚至上万个
那每个机油的话
这个就是那我发生的每一件事情
我怎么去通知到这些机油
那回到我们刚才这个例子里面
所以那在小明想做的这款战争游戏
我有这么多的
比如说NPC的大兵
我还有飞机
坦克大炮这些东西
那我怎么去管理它
这个时候就有一个管理的概念了
这里面就讲两个比较基本的概念
就是第一在我们的游戏实践中啊
我们每个机油一般都会给他一个唯一的编号
我们就也叫一个UID
就是unique id
其实刚才我上次上节课
讲到那个资源管理的时候
也会讲的就是它有一个GUID对吧
当我们全球进行唯一的标识
这个对这个就是现在游戏引擎非常重要
因为我们很多时候去标识定位这个物体的时候
就像你们家的门牌号一样的
我需要给你一个门牌号
另外一个的话呢
每个物体它在空间上基本上都是有各位置的
我们需要知道你的position
那好了
你们每个人都有唯一的标识了
然后呢不是不再是NPC12345了
而是说哎307405对吧
然后呢你们的位置有个经纬度
那这个时候我们就可以进行场景的管理
那最简单的管理是什么
最简单的管理是不管理
假设小明很粗暴说
反正我没有几个人
没几个兵的好
每一个阿莫的就是那个炮弹的那个component
里面
当我发生爆炸的时候
很简单
我把场景里所有的机油全部发一遍消息
或者说呢我做的稍微优雅一点
把场景里每一个机的位置查询一下
然后判断它的位置是小于我的爆炸半径对吧
一个一个爆炸半径好
我就告诉你说我对你有伤害的输出
这样写行不行
其实这样写也是可以的
如果大家做一些小游戏的话
没有问题
这样完全能跑得动
但是呢当我们场景中有
比如说几千到上万个机油的时候
这就会是一场灾难
为什么呢
因为这就是我们今天要讲的就是游戏
引擎的挑战
叫做N平方的挑战
什么意思
就是说我每一个物体都会可能
和其他的物体发生发生互动
如果每一次
我要和另外的所有的物体去问一遍呢
那就是N乘以N减一约等于N平方嘛
那么只要是N平方
比如说有1万个物体的话
N平方是多少
是一个亿
对不对
那这样会对计算机造成巨大的负担
尤其你的这些数据
如果分散在内存的各个地方的话
这个效率是非常低的
那么这个时候最简单的方法就来啦
比如说我们对世界画格子对吧
分而治之
Divide and conquer
这是大家最直觉的做法
其实画格子大家不要嘲笑他
我们把这个世界化成均匀的格子
然后呢就相当于你有一个门牌号
然后这个时候我就可以找我临近的格子
这个方法虽然听上去很简单
但其实在很多场景里面是使用的
比如说我的这个场景并不是特别大
那我就可以这样简单的画格子
那么它唯一会出问题的是什么呢
就是当这个场景物分布的不够均匀的时候
那么现在游戏中
我们的这个就是长期五分布的均匀
到底是均匀还是不均匀的
实际上呢是很不均匀的
我在以大家特别喜欢的这个
比如说3A大作主机游戏为例啊
在主机游戏中呢
其实你看的是一个很广阔的世界
对不对
但实际上你会发现作为一个玩家
我们能走的地方是非常受限制的
以前我们在国外做游戏研发的时候
我们这个叫做touch touch的意思是什么呢
就是那个那个打仗的时候挖的那个战壕
就是我们设计师会认为
就是我们给玩家挖了很多条RENCH
玩家只能在我们的这个账号里面走来走去
所以沿着站好
我们的东西会放得非常的详细和密集
当然账号之外是非常稀疏的
那这个时候如果你把这么大的世界
均匀的打格子的时候
同学们会发现是不是又慢又非常浪费
那这个时候呢
其实就有一个非常简单的算法来啦
就是说哎我们能不能够用一个层级结构
也就是一个hierarchy的架构去管理整个场景
刚才有聪明的同学告诉我
已经讲到八叉树了
说明很多同学是非常的厉害
已经做了预习
那么其实他的思想其实非常的简单
就是说就像我们的地图一样
整个世界很大
但是呢我们把世界分成国家
国家分成行省
行省分成城市
城市分成街区区
再分成街道
那这个时候假设有一颗有一个事件发生的时候
比如说我知道这是北京海淀区的某一条大街
发生的事情
那我很简单
我只需要在北京海淀区那个小区域里面去找
是不是就可以了
但实际上的话呢
这样的一个hierarchy的管理方法
就是一个非常有效的场景管理方法
那么它几乎就回到
我们刚才小明这个案例里面的话
我们可以根据这个地图上的这个
这些机油的分布
我们不断的比如说以空间的四差进行划分
对不对
如果这个地方人数假如是足够少
只有一个两个了
那我就不再划分了
如果人数很多
我就不停的划分
这样我就形成了这样的一个树状结构
大家同学们如果学过那个数据结构的话
就知道这是个典型的四叉树对吧
那么当我任何一个事件发生的时候
其实我知道我是在师大树的哪个节点
当我去寻找我的周边的时候
我只需要上上或者向下去寻找
或者找我的这个sibling
就是那个我的这个叫什么呢
叫兄弟节点对吧
或者我的parent节点
或者是我的那个那个那个那个sun节点
往下去找就可以了
这个呢是一个数据结构的课程
同学们不用钻的太深
其实非常的简单
因为实际上在游戏中的场景管理啊
随着现代游戏的发展啊
这个是一个最简单的策略
但实际上呢有很多的流派
比如说啊最简单的二叉树的流派
我们把世界按一刀一刀的把它分掉
那这个二叉树的画分呢
有的时候我们会做的更精致一点
比如说沿着墙去分
那么还有呢最经典的比如说八叉树对吧
刚才有同学已经提到了OCG
那orchestra的话呢也是一个非常经典的
对空间不断细分的一个方法
那么现在游戏引擎呢比较流行的是BVH
就是说我们用这个就是bounding box
就是每一个物体有一个小BINBOX
我们从小往大慢慢喝
慢慢喝慢慢合
当我去发生一个事情
或者说我作为一个一些比如说像一些计算
比如说最常见的是什么呢
这就已经跳课了
比如说世界追的裁剪
那我们就要用BBS快速的把很多东西全部扔掉
那么当我们去打出一条子弹
一个弹道的时候
其实我们也需要用这样的一个技术
去帮我们去快速定位
所以special的就是空间上的数据管理
是场景管理的核心
那么在真正的不同的游戏产品中的话呢
我们会采取不同的方法来解决它
比如说啊假设同学们做这个引擎
我们想做一个比如说呃2D的
像SUPERMARIA
就超级玛利亚这样的游戏
我们英文叫做planet former
这样的一个游戏的话
你可能就不需要这么复杂的场景管理了
但是如果你想做一个像cod啊
像quick这样的游戏的时候
那你一定要花心思去仔细的设计
你的款场景管理的方法
就是呢能够尽量节约你的计算资源
所以在我们这个案例中的话
小明的话我觉得他用一个就是说那个四叉树啊
或者是一个BFEH啊
基本上能够完成他的需求
所以呢到这一趴
我们的课程的核心内容
基本上就是给大家讲明白了
就是说其实在游戏中啊
所有的这个物体都是一个object
然后呢
每一个object呢都是用component base的方法去描述它
那用这个component组合出物体的不同的行为
那么就是说所有的component呢
我们用一个tick的方法
就会不断的去替他各自的逻辑去往前去走
那么在这个就是呃component里面的话呢
我们所有的机油之间通讯是什么呢
通过了一套复杂的消息机制来彼此进行通讯
那么我们在这么多物体在管理的时候
我们需要一套这个非常高效的
层次结构的场景管理机制
基本上听到这儿
我觉得如果动手能力比较强的同学
已经可以动手去构建
大家想要的这样的一个游戏引擎了
那实际上的话呢
就是说我们讲这个就是游戏引擎的话呢
真的大家是在商业学期做的时候呢
可能就有些更复杂的情况
我这里面的话呢
这一页就跟大家讲一些比较高能的东西了
举个例子啊
比如说在这个我们在游戏中
最常见的东西是什么呢
叫物体之间的绑定
那比如说像以我们大家都特别喜欢的深海
这个游戏里面
大家最喜欢的是什么
是开着车飙车对吧
那你开车的时候你是个机油
那车本身也是个CEO
但你那一刻你就被绑到车上面去了
对不对
那这个时候那个车在动你的
你的位移是被车锁锁定的
那你们两个之间的话该怎么去在一起联动呢
实际上这个时候我们在机邮局tick的时候
就有一个先后关系的问题
比如说我们一般会要求这个附节点腹肌会先替
可
然后呢我挂在上面的东西在后面T格
这样的话当我自己被踢开的时候
我会去问诶
我的车在哪里
我的车已经往前移了30cm的好吧
那我也往前移30cm吧
我在做相应的动作
但是呢这样的一个T课程序
当我就是说有更多的东西举个例子
比如说我们假设刚才讲的那个一个
一个component去听歌的时候呢
会变得相对复杂
但这件事情为什么这么重要呢
这个顺序这么重要
就是因为其实现在游戏中啊
当我们去T1个component的时候呢
我们很多时候是要分散到很多
很多的CPU上去执行的
就是他很多的T恤是并行执行的
而并行执行的时序是非常重要的
那这件事情的话呢
其实就引入了我们另外一个难题
就是我们刚才讲
就是说其实我们机构之间的通讯
是不是通过一个叫event event
就相当于我给你写信
就是我冲到你家门口
把游戏邮件塞到你们家门口的邮箱
对不对
但是这件事情它是有一个逻辑上的悖论的
这个悖论是什么呢
举个例子啊
就比如说大家在大学
有没有跟女朋友分手的经历啊
比如说当你去兴冲冲的写了一封封分手信
打算投送到你女朋友的寝室的时候
你突然发现你的女朋友也穿着衣服从寝室出来
手上拿着另外一封信
你那时候是不是马上要怀疑是是不是她的
同时给我也在写一封分手信
那到底是你耍赖你女朋友
还是你女朋友耍赖你呢
这件事你就讲不清楚了
对不对
我相信同学们在日常生活中
都会遇到这样的一个公案对吧
那这个时候其实在游戏世界里面
如果我们让GO直接彼此之间可以写信的话
它会产生很多我们叫做逻辑上的ambiguity
就逻辑上的混乱性
这个混乱性呢在很多时候你会注意不到
但实际上的话呢
对游戏的他的这个影响是非常大的
因为在游戏中啊
我们希望当用户是一模一样的输出的时候
我希望游戏世界里发生的行为他是确定的
一致的
不会变的
我们叫做deterministic
就是它的确定性
那举个例子吧
比如说同学们很喜欢玩各种对战游戏
对不对
当你打完了对战游戏之后
你最喜欢看的东西是什么
是精彩回放
而精彩回放本身呢
就是一个引擎提供的一种核心的能力
那一般的精彩回放是怎么做的呢
它并不是这个把刚才的你的游戏过程
整个状态全部都录了
像那时候那个录像的文件就会非常非常大
他是存不下来的
他怎么办
他只录了每一个小伙伴的输入
然后呢他把这个游戏重新又跑了一遍
但是呢重新跑了一遍之后
他和你刚才打的时候效果是一模一样的
那这个时候
如果大家所有的物体都是依次执行的话
那没有关系
一样的输入我一定跑出一样的结果
反正假设这个顺序是你负责先去送信
接下来才是你的女朋友的话
那你一定是你女朋友先于你收到这封信
对不对
所以你永远确保说嗯是我先甩了他
但是如果这个时候你们是并行的
就是分散到不同和尚
就是我们叫做多线程的运行的时候
它的结果就会完全不一样
大家能理解这里面的这个复杂度吗
那这个时候呢
我们就要引入一个很关键的第三方了
怎么办
我们要引入一个叫邮局
你们所有人都不许给彼此去直接写
投递这个信了
你们要比如说你要给你女朋友写信
你先把信寄到邮局去
然后邮局在统一时间把信发到每一个人
每个人都是统一的
第二天能收到你的心性
然后呢你第二天收到这个信之后
诶
我再去决定下一步的工作
比如说你女朋友看到你的这份分手信很生气
打算写一封信来骂你的时候
他也是只能当天晚上写完
然后再寄到邮局
第二天早上你才能收到
这样的话
我们能能就能确保它的时序是严格一致的
所以这个就是真实的在游戏引擎中
这个消息的传递啊
比大家想象的要复杂得多
所以刚才我讲的就像tick对吧
其实它是最简单的一个体格
但实际上的话呢在所有的component实现中
会有一个叫predict和POSTC这两个函数
它就是为了解决各种各样的实质性的问题
这种持续性的问题的话呢
在我们基于component base的这个
游戏世界构建的时候
实际上非常的重要
再举一个例子啊
就比如说呃我们这些component呢
大家其实是有一个依赖关系的
比如说刚才我提到诶
我要先动一下
比如说我现在MOTO告诉我说
你现在的移动速度是5米每秒
这个时候呢你的状态就从走路变成了跑步
对不对
那这个时候接下来我tick我的animation emission
说好的
我懂了
那我把我的动画从走路动画变成跑酷动画
但是其实呢那个animation呢它又会触发什么呢
触发我的物理
对不对
当我腿动了之后
我的这个物理的碰撞体是不是就伸出去了一下
对不对
伸出了一下之后诶
我说不定我的脚迈出这一下
我会撞到某一个东西对吧
或者是我的一些东西发生了变化
那么这里面当然今天我不讲了
过于复杂了
但是这些系统当我的状态发生变化的时候
它是不会反过来又会影响到我的位置
所以在我们真实的游戏引擎开发的时候
会经常遇到这种
就是说诶
他们彼此之间好像有那么一点点循环依赖
所以大家看到很多游戏他如果写的不够
那引擎写的不够好的时候
经常会发现有一个行为
他有大概一周到两人的lg就是说延迟
而这种lag的话呢
很多时候就是因为时序问题导致了
所以今天为什么我会花这么大的一页
跟大家讲这件事情呢
就是说其实当大家理解了什么叫做component
什么叫做tick
什么叫消息机制的时候
其实每一个组件他去替他去发消息
他的对象是在哪一帧
就是他之当前帧还是在下一帧才收到消息
收到消息之后是当场做动作
还是在等着做动作
其实对游戏的那个核心逻辑
影响是非常非常大的
那这个的话呢就是说我希望同学们
当大家兴冲冲的开始在做自己的引擎的时候
这一点一定要注意
就这个是游戏引擎最精妙的一个东西
这个就是那个我们这节课的主体内容
那这里面的话呢就是说我顺便再说一下
我们的小引擎
首先跟大家道个歉啊
我们那个本来上周要上线的小引擎
这个pilot的引擎被我们推迟了
那那原因呢
其实是确实是工作量比我们想象的大的多
我们课程组真的是他那些同学们非常的辛苦
然后我们最主要主要的原因就是
为什么要把这个相应情
就是这次作为一个大的改版呢
就是我我们上周在做code review的时候
因为我们本来是我们课程组分了两波同学
一波同学是专门负责写这个pilot的小引擎
给大家
另外一个同学准备课件
但是后来我们上周的code review发现
就是课程上讲的这些命名啊
这些写法结构和小引擎的实现有很大的差别
因为最大的差别就是我们当时想做e cs给大家
但是一旦上了ECS之后呢
这个小引擎的结构就会变得非常的复杂
所以我们后来经过整夜的讨论吧
到半夜我们做了一个很痛苦的决定
我们说那不行
我们得把相应请重新写
要按照课程的逻辑去写
为什么呢
因为否则很多基础就是没有太多基础的同学
跟不上
那也有很多同学问我了
说哎那这个小引擎的话
我们也想看ECS啊对吧
那有会不会有e cs这样的东西呢
首先的话呢就是在我们的课程的高级那一趴
会跟大家去讲ECS这套体系
那同时的话呢
就是说如果同学们会对这个东西感兴趣的
因为我们这个104课程呢是一个基础课程
面向很多可能基础不是那么强的同学
那我们后面的话呢随着时间的这个充裕的话
我们可能会准备一些专题
也会邀请同学们跟我们一起
我们深度的探讨就是基于ECS啊
基于这个面向数据编程啊
怎么样做更高的效率
当然我们也争取能够哎再搞一个版本
但这件事情我现在还不敢保证
因为我现在知道我们的团队他工作量非常大
但是好消息其实呢
就是我们争取在下周的release的时候
直接把动画系统和物理系统都放出来
所以大家看到这是我们相信现在的最新的效果
就是你们的角色是有简单的动画
和它的物理的碰撞
那为什么把它跟我们打算一起放出来呢
因为我们会发现就是说如果没有这些模块的话
大家看到的只是一个编辑器
而不是一个真的可以互动
可以playable的这样的一个游戏
所以呢有这个东西之后
同学们就可以基于它自由地放飞
构建各种各样你想要的东西
所以我们希望给大家创造一个相对好的基础
然后另外一个的话呢
就是那个就是我们的课程组一时兴起
还给我们小引擎设计了一个小小的图标
大家如果住的那个注意
注意到屏幕下面有一个小三角
那个像一个像一个小旗帜
像个小风帆的东西
就是我们的PIO引擎的图标
我们也希望就是这个小引擎的话
能够成为大家进入快乐的游戏引擎
航这个世界的这个嗯一个领路人嘛
这也是我们这个课程的一个一个
一个很humble的就是一个目标
我们很希望能达到这个目标
所以这里面的话呢
就是我要特别特别的感谢一下我们的课程团队
他们真的非常的辛苦
我们今天这个课件的话整整改了38版
这个是到今天晚上
我看来我们版本号已经升到了38
因为确实就是没有一个就是游戏引擎的这样的
一个一个就是现代游戏引擎这样的一个课程
然后呢每一节课怎么讲讲什么
怎么把一个比较晦涩的引擎设计的pattern模式
变成一个大家很容易懂得这样的一个案例
其实我们花了非常多的心血啊
其实爆肝做了很多东西
所以的话呢我是特别想
就是那个感谢一下我们的课程组的同学
然后呢
所以呢因为这也是我们第一次做这样的课程嘛
我们也很担心我们的课程讲不好
所以呢我们想做一个小小的调研调研问卷
就希望小伙伴们你们去扫一下这个二维码
然后告诉我们说诶你现在是在哪上学
就是你是上大学还是在上研究生
还是你在做什么工作
然后告诉我们课程哪个地方讲的不好
一定要讲的不好
包括哪些地方讲的
如果大家听不懂
也可以直接问我们
我们去给大家教
就是我们后面会调整我们的难度
或者大家觉得我们讲的太简单了
我们可以加入一些更深度的内容
所以的话呢就是也希望同学们和我们一起
打造一个精品的这个课程
我们也很希望就是说这个我们的games
104课程上完之后
我们的每个同学人手一个自研引擎
这也是我们104引擎
大家一起做的一个flag
如何好的
那今天呢我的课程的主体也就到此为止
那同学们有没有什么问题可以问我
啊对哇
这个同学问的很专业
就有同学问我们说如果一个tick时间过长的话
游戏引擎怎么处理
这个确实是在现代游戏引擎中
很常见的一个挑战
为什么呢
因为我们会假设说一个游戏
每隔呃就是30ms
我们会tick一次对吧
但是如果有的时候一个引擎
它的计算机就那一个T
可我的计算机过于复杂了
那我算不完怎么办
那机器只能算完
算完之后
那等我下次来的时候
可能已经过了40ms
已经过了这个60ms
但这里面处理方法有好几种
比如说一种最简单的处理方法是
我每个tick的时候呢
我会把那个部长传进去
这样的话比如像我的位移啊
现在这些东西我会把它补偿起来
这样人不太会注意得到
那么还有一种方法呢是我直接跳过一个tick
我就直接TK两针两针
但这个东西的话呢是比较比较危险的
那么实际实际上呢这个T和过程过长的话
一般来讲我们都会去优化
整个引擎和游戏的设计
举个例子吧
比如说当我们一个游戏
比如说发生了一个一个爆炸
突然一下子产生了很多物体的受击的这个事件
那这个时候一下子系统就处理不过来了
那这个时候呢我们有一种方法叫做differ的
这个processing
什么意思
就是说我们并不需要把这一件事情全部
比如说这几十个上百个物体都放在这一帧处理
我们会把它分成几批
一批处理20个
差个五帧处理完
因为五帧的话呢
在人的视觉中的话
还就是0.6秒到呃
呃呃0.2秒到0.2秒左右
所以有的时候大家还是能接受的了
所以这里面确实有很多的策略来解决这个问题
这个这个问题问得非常的专业
好的大家好
有什么问题
我看到问题刷得特别快啊
空气侠其实刚才举的不是一个特别好的例子
其实在游戏中啊
我们用的最多的这个看不见的机油呢
比如说像那个trigger
就是各种
如果大家打开这个一个游戏的编辑器的时候
你会看到很多非常多的这种
这个透明的这种东西
就是你走过去触发一个什么事件
比如说你在做单机游戏的时候
你走到一个地方
然后呢突然天上一个boss掉下来
开始虐你了
对不对
这个地方一般是个trigger发生的
像这种invisible object非常多的
那空气墙有时候也做机优势做事呢
比如说啊我们在做单机游戏的时候
我们会有个地方有一面墙
我不能让你跳过去
因为那边我没有做东西对吧
但是呢我一开始有几何又没有做的特别好
那怎么办
我会人为地放一个blocker放在那儿
把你给阻断
当然还有一些就是比如说我们做这个visibility
做做就是做那个视觉裁剪的时候
我们也会放一些看不见的东西
告诉你说这个你走到这儿的时候
可能我有些呃场景
有些东西我会加载
否则的话你会看到那边是空的
所以这里面的话直接看不见的东西会非常多
空气墙呢一般也会作为一个机油
但是呢有的时候我们会一个大机油就解决掉了
有的时候也会分成很多很小的机油
所以作为做引擎的人来讲的话
你就不用管了
你就反正就你随便你怎么定义它的shape
但是呢空气墙我们一般有一个建议
就是说都会用最简单的形体来构建
就是有不会直接导你的mesh
很多时候我们空气墙会用一些简单的面啊
圆柱啊
或者是一些参数曲面来表达它
哇我发现我的同学们都很专业啊
有个同学就在问我说check的时候
渲染线程和逻辑线程怎么同步啊
这是一个非常非常专业的一个问题
其实呢一般来讲就是我还记得我在上节课讲过
就是一般来讲两大神兽
tik render和TIK逻辑对吧
所以呢其实logic线程
一般来讲会和逻辑和渲染线程会分成两个线程
当我们一般TIK这个render的时候啊
TIK逻辑的时候是TIK
各位component的逻辑的部分
那么但是呢tik render的时候呢
他很多时候是做各种数据准备
包括一些render specific的东西
举个例子
比如像例子系统
它的tick就在render线程里面进行
那么实际上的话
现在呃在在现在的游戏引擎架构的时候
我们都都不只是一个线程做render了
可能是很多个线程在做这些
相应的准备和数据准备
所以的话一般来讲的话
但是如果从最简单的好去理解这个事情的话呢
我们一般会在tick logic产生的结果
会在tik render是在他后面
所以有的时候会如果引擎做的不好
会出现什么情况呢
就是逻辑会先跑一帧
然后你看到的画面又会延迟一帧
然后呢再讲一个更专业的
就比如说你画面准备好了
绘制出来你的FRAMEBUFFER
交换的时候又会延迟一帧
所以如果同学们在研究生在游戏引擎
你会发现就是我们以前有一个指标
就是当我在游戏手柄上做了一步操作之后
到我眼睛能看见这个延迟有多少
比如说大家很喜欢玩的
比如像XBOXPLAYSTATION的手柄
在最早期的时候
我们会发现这个可以达到100多毫秒
也就是三针到四针的lag
你才能感应感应到
但是呢我们做了大量的设计
让大家觉得这个东西打击感是很实时的
但这里面就有很多很深的一些trick在里面了
所以一般回到最原始的这个问题的话
就是啊tick logic会比tick render稍微早一点
而且呢我们一般会把它分成两个不同的线程
好的还有没有什么问题
同学们嗯
啊对其实这个同学问的也很专业
他说空间竟然划分了我那些动态物体
怎么办呢
其实这是真的是要处理的问题
为什么呢
因为我们不能够对整个场景每一帧都更新一些
但这是最简单的做法了
比如说我每一帧
我把空间中1000个物体全部再去生成一次
比如说二叉树
八叉树啊
但这个效率就特别低
大家如果以前学过数据结构的话
应该都学过叫树的这个插入和删除节点对吧
比如说有些节点消失了
我的有的有的节点要合并
如果有些节点插入了之后
我有些节点需要再一次再一次去分裂
包括有些节点发生移动了
我们去看怎么去表达它
所以呢其实刚才提到的几个算法
比如像BVH
比如说像那个啊BYH
就是那个包围盒的那个
那个就是那个绑定那个vertical
那个就那个volume的HRHI嘛
就是包括像那个BSP啊
像OCTREE啊
他们都会有一个共同的问题
就是如何去更新
一般来讲的话呢
就这也是我们在做游戏选择的时候
一般会选择那种更新起来比较比较
就是轻量的东西
我举个例子吧
比如说我们假设做一个室内的设计游戏
这个时候我们用那个就是啊二分世界
比如像P那个BSP税tree
或者p vs这个技术是可以的
因为这个世界基本上是静态的
我人只是人和小怪在里面走来走去
那我把世界进行静态划分
我甚至设置一些窗口啊
能看到彼此就可以了
但是的话呢
如果假设我想做一个像小明想做的一个
类战地这样的游戏
我是个open world
那你BSP的话呢
它更新起来第一个效果不太好啊
效率也并不会特别高
那这个时候呢其实用更简单的叫BVH会更好
因为BBH的话呢
它就是一大群物体的bd box
合来合去
它的算法其实你做的最简单的就是一个个的球
球的合并半径变得更大
所以呢
这个时候其实我更新的代价会非常非常低
那这样如果场景中所有的东西都动的话
那我们会推荐说你用BFEH效率会更高
所以这就是一个就是说如果我们做引擎的话呢
我们会推荐大家要支持两三种以上
比较经典的这种空间划分的算法
交给游戏产品
根据自己的需求去选择
好的啊啊这个问题我没听清楚
同学再说一遍
哪个模式哦
组件模式有什么缺点是吧啊
这个问题问的很挑战啊
组件模式呃
其实缺点还是很明显的
比如说啊组件模式
如果用最基础的一个实现的时候
它的效率肯定没有你直接写一个class
效率会高对吧
因为你每一次都要找到那个组件
找到它的接口去访问它
那么但是的话呢组件模式的话呢
就是这就是为什么我们后面要讲的高级课程
ESS很重要
就是说我们要把同样的组件全放到一起
把数据全放到一起
然后呢用方法快速的去处理这些数据
这样就避免了
就是说我们在切换的时候
它的成本特别的高
组件模式
第二个缺点是什么呢
就是说其实刚才我们讲的通讯嘛对吧
比如说我一个机油
比如说这个小小明他要发个消息给小美
那他之间的话又有一个event机制
对不对
其实组件之间的话
其实也要有一套通讯接口机制
而这个机制呢很多时候因为当我一个组件
他并不知道在同一个机构里面还有多少个组件
比如说我现在有一个组件叫做我的API对吧
那么API的话
假设我作为一个游戏里的人工智能的话
我的行为会发生变化
比如说我的血量很高的时候
我更有攻击性一点
对不对
当我的血量不够高的时候
我这时是不是更倾向于防御一点
那我就要不停的去问说哎我现在的血量多少
但是当我写AI组件的时候
我并不知道你有没有给我这个机油
挂了这个血量组件
所以我要不停的去query
就是去询问说
我有我有我有这个这个血量组件吗
如果有的话好
那告诉我现在血量是多少
而且你还告诉我绝对血量是多少
我这样我才能决定我的行为
而这个过这种query的过程的话呢
在一个非常高频的调用里面的话
其实他对效率的影响是非常大的
这也是组件模式本身带来的一个巨大的弊端
但是呢就是世界上的事情就是这样的
就是你凡事有利都有弊
所以说这就是我们愿意付出的代价
啊有个同学问了一个比较有意思的问题
就事件机制怎么去调试
这个其实是一个蛮难的一个问题
因为其实如果做真实的游戏产品的时候
大家会发现啊一帧的时候
那真的是很多很多条
这个就是这个事件
所以呢我们一般
比如说像很多引擎里面的做法是什么呢
比如说像unreal的蓝图对吧
你可以逐帧的去看它的走动
你可以看到这个时候一个GO多少个事件出来
比如像有些游戏里面的话呢
我们会锁定一个GO
然后呢我们会把这个CEO你现在发出去的
你现在收到了所有的消息
我们全部在你的头上顶出来
让你看到这个东西到底是怎么处理的
包括我们去这个
其实这里面讲一个非常黑科技的东西啊
其实在很多复杂的游戏里面
我们认为最有效的debug机制就是这个log
就是不停的打log
你可以在这个你的log文件里面找到
那一刻发生了什么事
那么当然当然当然了
就是游戏呢
它是一个就是啊就是艺术家的使用的工具
比如说对大量的这种
比如说啊非技术背景的同学
比如说像我们的设计师啊
很多时候他需要去debug
他的这个组件的行为的时候
我们还是会做很多可视化的方法
把这些消息
把每一个消息
消息后面带的这些内容
全部显示到3D的这个空间里面去
比如在游戏中有一个debug模式
我能让你看到所有的消息
这样的话我把这一帧pose注所有同学都看到哦
现在发出了什么消息
现在收到了什么消息
然后他判断说这个消息是不是没发出来
如果消息发出来啦
哎我这个机油
我这component不是没有处理
那这样的一个可视化的这种debug模式呢
现在的话呢也非常的多
所以的话呢这也是一个比较好的一种
就是第八个模式
但是实话实说
就是他肯定没有直接去掉那个东西很方便
而且的话呢就是真实的游戏里面
他的消息类型和种类是非常多的
所以这也是现在我们一个就是啊
重点在优化的东西
其实今天我们要讲的就是
其实像刚才讲的
如果所有人能把消息都寄到邮局
邮局都把消息发到所有人
其实大家可能没有注意到
就是这个消息的发送
接收分发本身如果做得不好
也会成为我们的游戏引擎的效率瓶颈
因为游戏引擎一个我在第一节课讲过
就是它最核心的挑战是什么
就是everything is real time
所有的东西都是要实时的
所以他要求效率非常的快
这个同学问的问题就比较难了
就是物理和动画互相处理的影响的时候
怎么去处理这个case呢
其实是比较比较复杂的
就是啊我们举一个例子吧
比如说呃
现在在很多游戏中有这么一个那个表现
就比如说当我一个人被受击的时候
那最早呢我们会把这个人切到一个布娃娃系统
对吧
那整个人就像没有骨头的人一样
这样就被打飞了
虽然看上去很物理真实
但是觉得好假
那我们的动画师呢就会设计一个动画
就是说诶我们把这个动画去
这个这个有一种很酷炫的一种表现
当然其实基于深度学习的话
会有一些更好的一个结果了
那今天不展开
那这个时候其实它物理和动画
彼此之间就会有影响
那讲个最简单的方法
比如说现在的很多主流的做法是什么呢
比如说我们是用插值的方法
比如在刚刚收集开始的时候
我先切动画的表现
然后呢越到后来我这个动画的这个位移
比如说我一打肩膀往后一靠
然后呢我的手一伸长
把这个东西作为我物理的出师输入
然后物理再去模拟
这样到后面越来越多的
我就把它交给物理去模拟了
这样的话当大家看起来的时候
就会觉得诶这个人倒地的姿势又很英雄主义
很有设计感
但同时又非常的物理的真实
最后他在地上躺在那的时候
那个手和脚的姿势也很随机
很真实
所以这就是一个很典型的
就是物理和动画和互相影响的这样的一个案例
好的那今天的话课程的话我们先到此这个结束
也今天这门课学完的话呢
就今天这节课程
我觉得同学们基本上就可以尝试去
构建自己的引擎了
当然你要解决渲染的问题
在渲染的问题的话
相信后面的节课我们会大家讲
就是游戏引擎的渲染的基础课
那我们的课的话呢
不会讲过于详细的渲染的算法
而更多的会告诉大家
就是在游戏的这个引擎里面
怎么去
怎么去组织这些渲染的数据结构和它的算法
选择这些算法
所以的话呢就是同学们的话呢
如果有更多的问题
可以到我们的微信群里面继续问我们
然后另外一个就是也欢迎大家
就是希望大家帮我们去做一下这个SWE
告诉我们说我们的课程在什么地方做的不好
什么地方需要优化
我们也希望和大家一起把这个课程
就是越做越好好的
最后谢谢大家